and welcome to this talk about android
automotive
um
so i'm going to tell you about
what's going on in
the
automotive industry and why android is
becoming very popular with these guys
um skip that bit
a little bit about myself um so i'm a
trainer and um and freelance engineer
i've been doing this stuff for quite
some time i've been doing stuff with
embedded linux
for 20 or something years
and i wrote a book about the subject
just saying it's quite a good book
and i'd like to make a disclaimer about
my relationship with google which is
that i don't have one
so this is in no way spell sponsored by
google i've never signed an nda with
google so this is entirely my own work
so having said all that then what i want
to do then is to talk a little bit about
android and how it's been deployed
in the automotive industry
as a means of
controlling the the ivi system
so here's the
first example of a
vehicle you can actually go and buy uh
which has um
uh android automotive embedded uh this
is the good old polestar
and there's the
very prominent android display there in
the middle
which does look a little bit like it's
been glued it like like a tablet has
been glued onto the dashboard but that's
the way it looks
so android as i google have been
interested in android
in the car for quite some time
so they started off 2014
uh talking about a thing called android
auto now a lot of you probably use
android auto so this is where you have
your smartphone
connected either via bluetooth or sorry
connect either via a usb or maybe wi-fi
to the head units
but in that case the intelligence the
application is running on the phone and
the head unit is really just providing a
screen
2017 they came up with
automotive os
which is what i'm talking about
so this is android running actually in
the head unit
oh yeah little thing at the bottom there
it turns out this is not the first time
anybody has used android for a head unit
um particularly the
those manufacturers i mentioned there
have been running android in the head
unit for quite a long time you can kind
of see though that because they did
their own port of android
um they've kind of got stuck on old
versions in some cases very old versions
of android
but now this is part of google's plan
for android
so
this is the
this is the way that a lot of people are
doing it now
so the first thing to say then is that
android automotive os is open source
it is part of the aosp the open android
open source project
so anybody can download this stuff and
build a system from it
however
um
what you get from the open source
implementation is not really production
ready
um you need to do some customization
uh of the home screen at the very least
the home screen as the default home
screen is not really very usable
uh you need some applications which
actually interface with the vehicle
and do things like turning lights on and
off and
making windows go up and down and that
kind of stuff
um and you need the back end services
for navigation
uh speech recognition
uh that kind of thing
so google have a solution for this of
course
it's called google automotive services
gas
so this is a
um
a licensed package of software you get
from google
uh so it includes play store includes
navigation
uh google assistant so you can do
hands-free driving pantry commands and
such like
um it's not free so there's a per unit
license
and in order to get that license you
have to pass a whole bunch of tests
including
the compatibility test suite the
vendor test suite and the automotive
test suite and possibly some others
which i
don't know about
and you must deploy google's apps
you can't for example replace the
navigation with your own navigation
you've got to use google maps
now not everybody is happy with this
so some
auto manufacturers are
taking the open source
android
and they are implementing their own
services
and there are companies that do
basically sdks you can purchase
to to do all this stuff
so you're going to see a combination of
uh pure
pure google implementations of aos
plus a number of um
of
non-google
implementations with non-google play
stores and such like
so this is what um android automotive
looks like
so
starting at the bottom down here
we have the vehicle ecu's
uh electronic control units
so these are the things which are
controlling all the bits and pieces in
your car
so they're doing some trivial things
like turning lights on and off the
headlights and such like
and they're doing some major things like
controlling the engine the engine
management unit is one of
these these are all connected together
via some kind of vehicle bus
most cases this is going to be canvas
and then the interface between the ecu's
and android is a hal
pal is the hardware abstraction layer
and the particular how we're talking
about here is the vehicle hull
so the vehicle hal is
interfacing between the vehicle bus and
the rest of android
the hull then is talking up to the next
level up which over here if i get my
light to work um so the next level up is
the car service
so this is a system service part of the
android operating system and it is
holding the state
um
and and presenting apis
to applications
based on the information from the
vehicle how we or be how
then above that we have a library uh
this is android car.jar so this is the
the
library that applications will link with
in order to access the services
and then on top of that we have the
applications
so it's a fairly standard
four layer cake as you get with
most android
implementations
so i'm going to go through that in a
little bit of detail so i'm going to
start off by talking about the v-hull
so the v-hull then is
collecting signals from the from the
vehicle bus from the can bus
and storing them
in vehicle properties
so a vehicle property is essentially a
data point
which contains
um
typically a measurement
so um yeah one example would be the
speed of the vehicle
so that is relayed from
wherever which whichever ecu knows how
fast you're going
there's relayed uh to that vehicle how
that's stored in a property called
vehicle speed which is in meters per
second
so another one would be the uh cabin
control the cabin temperature control so
that's a knob on the dashboard you flip
that round to whichever temperature you
you want
that is
passed down to the vehicle hal
from the application
and then passed to the heating control
unit
as a value in degrees celsius or
something
so everything goes through the vehicle
properties
so as you can see some properties are
read from the vehicle from the vehicle
bus say the speed for example that's
read directly from an ecu
some properties are controlling the
vehicle so for example we could have a
slider on the screen which sets the
cabin temperature
that then transmits a value to the heat
and control ecu which then sets the
cabin temperature
um the properties are well there's a
bunch of properties 150 it says there
yeah
predefined by aosp
and here is one of them
so this actually is the heating
target temperature
so you can see it's defined here it's
given a unique number 503 in this case
as a floating point number and it says
up here that it can change
and the access should be read and write
so if you look through that particular
file
um
yeah you good uh there's a file
reference down here types.hal if you're
looking type.how you'll find
uh 150 roughly speaking of these things
plus a bunch of other stuff
now the properties the default
properties defined in type start how are
just the the basic stuff
every vehicle is different
so there will be
vendor properties so you can extend the
properties by adding your own vendor
properties
and you do it something like this
the key point here is that there are two
property groups one called system one
called vendor the vendor stuff goes in
the vendor group
so
um
yeah i've just got a property called
vendor example which isn't very uh
intelligent perhaps but you can see you
define it you give it some number so
this number has to be unique
um
the group is vendor you give it the type
32 bit integer maybe
and global indicates
yeah this refers to the entire vehicle
annoyingly yeah you end up having to do
this twice over
because you'll need to reference this
variable from uh from c plus plus so
you'll declare it like that you also are
going to end up needing to access this
from java so you'll have to put it into
a java class somewhere
and then the
the interface to the v hal is a binder
interface
called i vehicle
so every time you want to access these
properties you send a message to the
vehicle hal on ibinder
and the functions it provides are this
bunch
um so the first of just meta stuff so we
can get information about the properties
property configurations that's just
enumeration stuff
but the interesting stuff then is we can
get a property we can set a property
and we can subscribe to a property
for example
yeah this this diagram could do with
some work i apologize for that
but here we have a simple case we have a
an application car app
that is talking to the service to
um
it wants some information for example he
wants to monitor the vehicle speed
so it says to the car service give me
the vehicle speed
the car service will then subscribe
to vehicle speed from the vehicle how
so that's then launched with the v hal
daemon
um
that this
uh this application is now subscribed to
this value
and then the ecu when it feeds a new
value back to the vehicle how
the v hull is then going to send a
callback
an i-vehicle call back on change to the
car service that will then transmit the
change to the applications interested
so this means that we can efficiently
monitor changes to properties and feed
them all the way from the ecu
up to the application
android automotive os defines um three
different
modes of change so properties are either
static never change
on change
so that means that they change
intermittently
and we want to know as soon as the
change happens
so for example the gear selector
um forward reverse park drive whatever
we want to know as soon as that gear
selector has changed because that's
going to you know that's something we're
interested in
or the door unlock we want to know
immediately that the doors are unlocked
whatever
so on change we want to know immediately
the value changes
and then continuous this is for things
which are always changing
so the speed the temperature that kind
of stuff
um
so an unchanged notification wouldn't
work there so in this case we label it
as being continuous and then we set a
sampling rate in hertz as to how often
we want to be notified of that change
so if it's the temperature you probably
want to be notified maybe once every 10
seconds or something
if you're monitoring the speed you
probably want to be notified maybe 10
times a second or something
so that's the fee how
then above that we have
the car
service
so the job of the car service is to take
the raw properties from the v how
and make them into useful apis that
applications can use
[Music]
this is some information that isn't that
useful if you're if you're working
directly with um android automotive os
the most useful thing here is you can
use a command called dump sys dumps this
car service tells you a lot of
information about what the
service is doing
gives me a second
and then on top of the car service is
the car manager so in android terms
for every system service there is a
manager the manager is the api to the
service
um so the car manager is a
jar file called android.car.jar which
ends up in the system framework
directory of your device
and
the apis are a bunch of android car
classes
and there is documentation for them at
this link here
not a huge amount of documentation
unfortunately they're not
heavily used at the moment
so
when you go to developer.android.com and
look at that class you don't find a huge
amount there before unfortunately
so within the car manager we have a
bunch of
uh
services or a bunch of interfaces i
should say
so confusingly
they are it kind of shells out into um
23 different interfaces and they're all
listed here which i'm not going to go
through every single one of them i'll
leave you to read them at your leisure
but just to give you an example next a
few slides i am
picking out a few
uh just to demonstrate the kind of
things you're going to see there
so we're going to look at property
service info service
use their
usage restrictions
or user experience research restriction
i suppose it should be
a bit of a digression on to android
permissions
so
if you're familiar anybody here written
android apps any android app programmers
here
okay
a few
in that case let me go through this
very briefly then in order to access um
various features very components of
android you have to declare in your
application manifest your android
manifest xml file various permissions
and then the system either grants you
the permission or not depending
so android permissions are the main way
of restricting
what applications can do
so in
the case of automotive
we have a set of android permissions
which uh you need to access very various
parts of the vehicle
[Music]
the majority of these permissions are
marked
and again this depends on you being
familiar with android they're marked as
being signature or privileged
um
in essence this means that these
permissions will only be granted to
applications that are built as part of
the system and installed on the system
partition
so these permissions are never granted
to third-party apps
in fact when it comes to third-party
apps
these are the only permissions
that you will be able to access
so car info
read display units set display units
energy ports powertrain speed energy
everything else all the all the
nitty-gritty stuff to do with turning
the lights on and off making the windows
gotten down locking and unlocking the
doors
those are system permissions only
available to system apps
which probably is a good thing
um so the permissions are per property
so
there is a permission for example vendor
sorry permission vendor extension which
is required if you want to access any of
the access any of these vendor
permissions
as i described earlier
so again that means if you're putting
together an android automation
android automotive system
then you will
need system apps in order to access the
vendor defined permissions
and properties
okay can i just pause there because i
notice my laptop is
flashing red here and it's about to shut
down and i hope
i put the cable in
otherwise this could be short
okay it looks like i didn't put the
cable in
no
just be aware the screen may go blank at
any time
so here's some examples of some of those
services i mentioned
um
the first one is a simple one called car
info service
um car info manager i should say
so this is available to anyone and it
just gives basic information about the
vehicle
so
the manufacturer the model the year the
type
um just basic stuff so anybody can read
this stuff this permission level is set
to normal which means anybody can read
this
[Music]
an interesting one then is the
user experience restricted service
so this is really to enforce the driver
distraction rules so essentially we
don't want
drivers accessing applications whilst
driving so we don't want them
watching youtube or
playing video games
so these are
controlled by
this this service
so this service is a very simple one it
basically says are we in driver
distraction mode on yes or no and it
returns yes or no
if you are in
driver distraction mode in other words
the vehicle is being driven
then it will prevent you from running
certain applications
okay there are a bunch of other services
like i say i'm just going a couple of
examples and those are the only two i'm
going to talk about
and then on top of the so we have the
car services the car manager which is
the library and then on top of that we
have the applications
so at the application level we get some
very basic apps as part of the
aosp the android open source project
and this is the list
so we get a home screen
um
uh
which i'll show you in a couple of
slides time
and we get some very simple mock-up apps
so there's a there's a hvac app which
mocks up um seat temperatures and such
like
there's a media player app which
pretends to play media although it
actually doesn't do anything
there's a car maps placeholder which
just displays a green screen it doesn't
even pretend to display a map
and so on so essentially what you have
to do as a vehicle manufacturer is go
through and implement working versions
of each of these
and that's a non-trivial exercise
i'm talking briefly about displays
so vehicles typically have more than one
screen
so this is a shot of the instrument
cluster display
so this is a separate display
um
[Music]
which android can project to
and the reason i say project is if we
look on the next screen
the instrument cluster is a safety
critical component
because it's displaying important things
like the speed and various other
vehicle status information
android is not a safety critical
operating system
it can crash at any time
so we don't want to use android for
safety critical things
so the way we do this is that there is a
separate um
controller
uh handling the vehicle uh the outside
the instrument cluster
and
it's typically a separate
uh processor
uh it's running a different operating
system typically qnx or something like
that something that is safely certified
and then android can project
an image to that um cluster controller
as a video stream a h264 uh stream and
then the video controller sorry and then
the cluster controller uh can
display that in a suitable rectangle
and the service that does that i
mentioned that i've in passing on the
slide is the instrument cluster service
um
which
uh has some apis which basically allows
you to request focus on the cluster and
then use it to display
essentially a screen
or a sequence of screens
so then um
as well as the applications written by
the vehicle vendor
we have third-party applications
so these are
typically downloaded through the app
store so if you haven't licensed google
automotive services
then you'll get access to play store
however the
applications you can access and install
at the moment at least are very
restricted
so there's a note there that says google
takes driver distraction very seriously
your app must meet specific design
requirements um
before it can be listed on play store
for android automotive and android auto
so i take that to mean that
when you submit an automotive or auto
app
uh to play store
that somebody is going to
check whether that is
meets the guidelines
and give you some kind of feedback if it
isn't
so the types of applications you can
write for automotive
and android auto
are basically these
so you can do media apps
media meaning audio
so these are typically things like
streaming media like spotify
um internet radio is a good one
audiobooks
very popular
that kind of thing
uh messenger apps
so these can display uh short
notifications on the screen
uh but typically the main functionality
would be in text to speech to read out
messages and speech to text which would
allow you to respond to messages
um
and then fairly recently well maybe six
months ago now they added a third
category which are navigation type apps
so this allows you to write applications
that
uh for example display charging points
and allow you to navigate to the nearest
charging point
for example
if you're developing for android
automotive
then android studio supports automotive
you need the latest version of studio
for this to work
and
you need to install the appropriate
sdk
and then that will allow you to
create an avd an android virtual device
which looks like a vehicle
so this is the abd you get you get
basically this screen this is a screen
here
and then all the rest of it is just a an
image to make it give you the feeling
that you're actually in a vehicle
okay so that's the main part of what i
want to say
um oh
let me come back to the moment yes so
how many applications actually are there
out there
i haven't checked it recently but when i
did check maybe about six months ago
um i found there are a few hundred
applications that you can use with
android auto
maybe four hundred or something
um on on play store
for applications specifically for
automotive os
i counted 30 something
so it's not as if there are a million
applications you can install on your
vehicle it's more like a few dozen
now that i'm sure will change over time
but at the moment yeah it is for these
for very good reasons uh restricted as
to which applications you can actually
run on your head unit
okay
so next topic i want to talk a little
bit about exterior cameras
so
most modern vehicles most new vehicles
have rear-facing cameras
which give you the the view behind the
vehicle as you reverse
and they may do additional things i may
draw a little grid which gives you the
expected course as you reverse
some of the more sophisticated ones also
have object recognition things so they
can flash up saying you you're about to
reverse into
uh a traffic ballot or something
and typically these cameras are going to
be handled by the
head unit
because it's got a nice big display in
the middle of the vehicle
so but there's a problem here
android as you know when you turn your
android phone on
it doesn't immediately turn on if you've
turned on front from from scratch
it has to do a cold boot and that takes
20 40 60 seconds or something
now in the case of head units it's
normal that the head unit is actually
fully powered off
vehicle manufacturers don't like having
um
things taking up
power they taking up current because it
runs the battery down so if you leave
your vehicle in the garage for
maybe four weeks while you're on holiday
you don't want to come back to find the
batch has been drained by the ivi unit
so typically the ivr unit is fully
powered off when the ignition is off
which means that when you turn the
ignition on you've got to do a cold boot
each time
so how do we get the camera display
operational
in
the regulation of two seconds
so particularly in the us it says within
two seconds of turning the ignition on
you must have that rear view display
present
so the way to do that is there's a
subsystem called the evs the exterior
view system
um which can do this
so the evs is basically as pretty much
completely separate from android
it's a native daemon as written in c
plus plus
um doesn't have any dependencies on the
rest of android
so it can come up very quickly
so it's the longest you can get android
we'll get to the android init program
within maybe one second
you've got maybe one other second a
second second
to
bring up the evs application and start
streaming video from the review camera
to the to the screen
so that's what all this stuff here does
oops it's not working
so just a quick look at this then so
there is
a path from the camera driver
up through the application to the evs
application
within the evs application that's where
you do the um
any manipulation of the images like
drawing a grid doing object detection
that kind of stuff
and then you feed the frames back down
uh to the display
typically the the console display
and um yeah that's what the driver sees
and then the
there are some links over here to the
right hand side
where we need to talk to the v hal
because the v hal knows which gear has
been selected
so essentially it's doing
a subscribe
on the vehicle on the gear selection
so when the gear selection goes to
reverse that triggers
the evs and you get the rear view
so here's a little diagram showing how
that works
so essentially from
the top here from boot up it's just kind
of looping
waiting for input from the v-hal
actually doesn't
literally loop it actually doesn't
subscribe as i described just now so
it's just waiting on the for an
unchanged
on the gear selection
so when the gear selection becomes
reverse
uh the evs system jumps in takes over
the display and displays the
uh display the camera view
and there's two little boxes here do it
with this one for change there's two
little boxes here because some vehicles
have uh side view cameras
in the place in replace to replace uh
side mirrors
so if you indicate left or right
that will show the side view
so same thing
um
[Music]
yeah so one of the consequences of this
is that when the evs application is
invoked because you've selected reverse
gear
that essentially grabs the display from
android so whatever you were watching
previously disappears whatever's on
display previously disappears and you
get the camera view full screen
until you then move into a forward gear
okay um
next topic
uh yeah
so let's talk a little bit about car
audio
and
what um android does for that
so audio is a tricky thing in a vehicle
so whereas with a smartphone
audio is pretty simple you've got a
microphone
one or two speakers
and maybe a a jack that you can plug in
headphones
in a vehicle it's very much more
complicated
you've got multiple output channels
you've got speakers all over the place
um
you know smart
fancy cars have maybe uh 16 or 18
speakers in the cabin
you have microphones and lots of
different places to pick up
voice
um
and then you have headphone
uh jacks particularly for the rear seat
passengers so they can plug in
and listen to you know whatever
without distracting the driver
so it's a lot more complicated
so there are some changes to android
automotive uh to handle this
um
[Music]
the the main thing is so here's here's a
diagram from uh
developer and oh sorry source to
android.com
so up here at the top we have a number
of applications each producing uh audio
streams so there's the navigation app
there's the
uh radio app there's a streaming media
app and so on
so they are feeding uh those streams to
a thing called surface to audio flinger
so audioflinger is essentially the audio
mixer in android
so that's taking all these channels
together and then it does a sub mix
mixes down into a smaller number of
channels
and this is the this is the main thing
that's different between
android automotive and regular android
so with regular android you have
basically just one output from
audioflinger
with android automotive you have
as many as you want
so these are called buses
and each bus is an output from the audio
flinger that's then fed into the audio
amplifier
and that's then fed to an appropriate
set of speakers
so we can feed these we can essentially
we can route the audio to different sets
of speakers
and we do that based on the content of
the audio
so
a good example would be the navigation
app
its audio stream will be
tagged has been
type navigation
that will be detected in audio flinger
and then audio flinger will then route
that typically to the driver side of the
vehicle because the driver is probably
more interested in the navigation than
anyone else
so these are the audio context so within
android you can label an audio stream
with a context
here's a an example
or some examples
and then
those contexts are
mapped down into
buses
and yeah here's my example about the
navigation context typically being used
to select routing towards the
towards the driver
there's one other interesting thing
uh yeah looking at this diagram here
over at the bottom at the left-hand side
it says chimes and warnings
so vehicles
are
regulated to make certain noises when
you do certain things so if you engage
reverse gear it may play some kind of
noise
if you indicate left or right that has
to play some kind of noise
plus there may be
status update from the vehicle itself
if the engine is not working correctly
or something
so these are called chimes and warnings
many of them are mandated by by
regulations so you have to do this
and it's an error if they don't
play correctly
so once again because android is not a
safety critical operating system
the chimes and warnings are not played
through android
instead they have to be routed directly
to the vehicle audio system
yeah that's basically all i have to say
on that
yep
okay we're getting through this at quite
a good rate
um
so that's pretty much everything i
wanted to say just give you an
introduction to how the whole thing fits
together what it is what it does
so
android android automotive os this is
android for the vehicle
um so it's android as you know it but
with a bunch of changes made to make it
work within the vehicle context
and i've mentioned a bunch of those
in this presentation
um
and and and and that's it actually
hang a second we haven't quite finished
so first of all then do we have any
questions on any of that
we've all been very very quiet and
attentive so
yeah anybody working in automotive
anybody
have experience of any of these things
or any questions at all
exactly yes
so
well so that the iv is every vehicle has
now has an ivi system so the ivi is the
the music system it's the navigation
system
it's the heating and control system
it's the
um turning lights on and off system and
that kind of stuff so it does a bunch of
key things to
to the vehicle
plus
um it's entertainment from the from the
driver's point of view as i'm driving
along i want to be able to listen to the
radio and so on
so
every vehicle manufacturer at the moment
has an ivi system
they're mostly based on embedded linux
using yocto project
and using a thing called agl which is
automotive grade linux which is a yakuto
thing
and
i'm sure you've used these things and
they're usually terrible
so people don't don't like the
proprietary ivi systems
they cost a fortune to develop so each
manufacturer has a team of hundreds of
engineers building these ibi systems
which everybody hates
um
and the big problem at the moment is
they don't have
an app store or if they do have an app
store it's pretty poor
so
two things then first of all
there is a drive from the from the
manufacturer's point of view they want
to reduce development costs
so instead of developing their own ivi
system
they are going to outsource it to google
who gives them for free in quotes an ibi
system which is fully functional
so the big draw from the manufacturer's
point of view is cost reduction the
other thing is that
the android environment is um
uh is based on java and and you know
android programming is is is well known
and easy so it's much cheaper to hire
android programmers than it is to hire
c plus plus programmers who know cute
um you know that's an expensive skill
that's true
uh no no no so it will integrate the so
that the the ibi system will integrate
also the knobs and buttons on your
on your vehicle so you'll have knobs and
buttons on the steering wheel possibly
some on the console whatever each one of
those knobs and buttons actually is an
ecu
so they're all connected to the can bus
they feed that through to the head unit
and that can then
do stuff with it
so that can feed into the radio app and
turn the radio on and off for example or
turn the lights on and off
so
the
i i agree touch screens and vehicles are
a really bad idea go tell tesla um
but
the the physical knobs on are not
connected to anything directly they are
just providing a single signal via can
bus you still need an application to
read that signal and do something useful
with it
so that that's where it fits in
wouldn't the controls circumvent no well
it's got to go somewhere so if you if
you have a knob you have a rotary knob
that's producing a sequence of you know
increments
up or down but something's got some
piece of software has got to read that
knob
and do something with it so that's the
ibi system
that used to be linux now it's becoming
android
so the requirement the need for the ibi
system still remains
so it's a complete study
um i'm
i don't know that
i'm not quite sure i understand the
question
okay yeah so yes yes yes
i i don't have any details on nvidia
drive i'm afraid so i can't really
comment
so in my experience is not particularly
popular
but
i don't know i'll talk to you afterwards
maybe
um okay anything else
okay well thank you all very much for uh
for being here and listening to me uh
ramble on
um i hope some of this is useful um
details on the on the screen is where
you get the slides and contact me
and um happy to talk to you around the
uh presentation around the the show in
the next
day and a half so thank you all very
much
[Applause]
okay and don't forget to vote on your
way out
the green ones are special
so